was bedeutet es denn auch mit Blick auf
Putin wenn wir immer wieder rote Linien
hin malen und sagen das machen wir nicht
das machen wir auf gar keinen Fall das
machen wir auch nicht dann kommt das
Carsten und dementiert zumindest nicht
dass irgendwann der Tag kommen könnte an
dem wir auch Kampfjets liefern könnten
und sagt er Kanzler auf Südamerika-Reise
auf gar keinen Fall das muss jetzt mal
Ende haben und immer diese Eskalation
und dieser Überbietungswettbewerb so
geht das nicht weiter welchen Eindruck
macht das auf Sie na gut sie sprechen ja
jetzt gerade auf den Konflikt zwischen
Frau esken und Herrn Scholz an den fand
ich auch tatsächlich bemerkenswert fand
aber eigentlich die Äußerung des
Kanzlers fast erklärungsbedürftiger als
die von VVS gehen weil
Herr Scholz ja was gemacht hat was die
SPD ausdrücklich versucht hat zu
vermeiden über die letzten Wochen und
Monate nämlich eine rote Linie hat ja
gesagt wir ziehen da keine rote Linien
bestimmen uns immer mit allen Partnern
ab
entscheiden von sozusagen von Monat zu
Monat je nach militärischer Lage und so
weiter das war eigentlich die
Sprachregelung die der sehr ursprünglich
vorgegeben hatte er hat sie selbst
konterkariert und beim Thema Kampfjets
das fand ich ehrlich gesagt hochspannend
ob das durchzuhalten ist
weiß ich nicht es ist ja schon häufig
vorgekommen dass sozusagen auch der
Kanzler selbst lange gezögert hat am
Ende dann doch das gemacht hat was er
längere Zeit das ist das Muster die
ganze Zeit ist dass das Muster genau
am Ende doch zu machen genau wobei ich
sagen würde ich habe ein gewisses
Verständnis dafür dass man sozusagen in
diesem Krieg nicht Hals über Kopf und
permanent irgendwelche neuen
Waffensysteme fordert sondern sondern da
behutsam vorgeht abwägt ich meine das
ist ein hochgefährlicher Krieg ja in
unserer unmittelbaren
Nachbarschaftsrecht der jederzeit
komplett eskalieren kann und wir haben
es natürlich mit einem Menschen im Kreml
zu tun ganz gerade gesehen ja der ein
eine Irrationalität an den Tag gelegt
hat indem er diesen Krieg überhaupt
gestartet hat das war gegen seiner
persönlichen Interessen eigentlich das
war gegen die Interessen Russlands ja
und diesen
irrationalitätsfaktor würde ich niemals
ausschließen auch in den kommenden
Monaten ich glaube der ist nicht
berechenbar dieser Mann ja deswegen
spricht viel für diese Behutsamkeit
gleichwohl finde ich es auch ein
bisschen kurios wie der Bundeskanzler
dann versucht seine Behutsamkeit zu
einer wohlüberlegten Strategie sozusagen
zu machen ja das ist ja offenkundig
nicht der Fall man muss sich nur mal die
leopard-entscheidung dann angucken vor
zwei Wochen die wurde kommuniziert als
große panzerallianz und es war genau
[Musik]
Stolz hat sich hingestellt im Bundestag
einsperrt einen Tag später hat gesagt es
war genau richtig dass wir gewartet
haben dass wir mit allen gesprochen
haben dass wir es genau geplant haben
jetzt stellt sich raus wo richtig
geplant war offensichtlich nicht weil
wir Merkel schon äh richtig bemerkte
viele Europäer haben jetzt
offensichtlich ihre Schwierigkeiten mit
den Leopard Lieferungen entdeckt ja und
machen nicht mit und da denkt man sich
dann natürlich schon okay wenn er Scholz
die Zeit hat ja zu planen und zu reden
und sich mit Verbündeten abzustimmen
dann passiert aber offensichtlich nichts
zerstört das seinen narrativ ein
strategischer Großmeister zu sein jetzt
müssen wir ein bisschen sortieren weil
der in Amerika auch sehr zu Hause ist
wie war das an diplomatisches
Meisterstück oder war das am Ende
einfach die Einsicht der Amerikaner okay
dann machen wir es eben so ist ein
Wahrheit eine große eine große
Enttäuschung zu bemerken ja da war schon
hinter den Kulissen und ich glaube im
Spiegel ist das ja glaube ich
dargestellt worden da war schon ähm auch
einige Verärgerung da wir haben ein
unglaubliches Glück mit diesem
Präsidenten Präsidenten ist angetreten
als ein Transatlantiker jemand der
übrigens regelmäßig bei uns auf der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz war er hat
glaube ich selbst dran gelitten wie
unter Präsident Trump diese Tante
atlantischen Beziehungen schlecht
gelaufen sind und und wie es wie
wirklich da ja ein wirklich große
Differenzen gab und er hat sich
geschworen ich du alles um das
Verhältnis zwischen Amerika und Europa
gut zu belassen um zwischen USA und
Deutschland das eben nicht so zu werden
wie es unter Trump war diese
Entscheidung war eine Entscheidung die
er dem Bundeskanzler zuliebe gemacht hat
ganz sicher um da eben keine Lizenz nur
das kann ich das Muster der Zukunft sein
wir können nicht bei jedem künftigen
Konflikt oder wenn es dann dann wir
wissen nicht in welche Richtung das geht
oder wo es andere Konflikte noch gibt
Amerika wird nicht auf Dauer in Europa
den Polizisten spielen können das können
Sie für sich nicht die chinesische
Herausforderung haben wir zu Beginn
gesprochen da muss ich die müssen nicht
die Amerikaner darauf konzentrieren wir
wissen nächstes Jahr überhaupt noch da
genau und wir müssen wir müssen in
Europa unsere Hausaufgaben machen wir
haben einen riesen Glück und wir können
nicht davon ausgehen dass diese Zeit die
Normalität hinzunehmend sein deswegen
die Frage an Saskia essen
fällt denn dann die nächste Rute Linie
sozusagen also
Kampfpanzer
Kampfjets Entschuldigung an die Ukraine
schließen Sie jetzt aus oder würden Sie
sagen der Moment kann kommen ich stimme
ich stimme erstmal zu ganz klar wir
müssen unsere Hausaufgaben machen aber
wir sind im im Hier und Jetzt und wir
müssen hier und jetzt agieren und
deswegen war es richtig und entspricht
im Übrigen auch der Linie die der
Kanzler immer vorgegeben hat und immer
deutlich gemacht hat wir stehen
unverbrechlich an der Seite der Ukraine
und unterstützen sie in ihrer
Verteidigung gegen den Aggressor aber
wir tun es nicht alleine und das heißt
so eine Entscheidung das ist schon auch
eine schwerwiegende Entscheidung es war
auch klar die Putin die jetzt
propagandistisch auch ausnutzen würde
dass wir Leopards liefern so eine
Entscheidung ist nicht zu treffen ohne
ähm im Geleitzug eben gemeinsam zu
agieren mit
mehreren Verbündeten wichtigen
Verbündeten insbesondere mit den USA
dass diejenigen die vorher laut gerufen
haben zum Teil
laut gerufen haben wie beispielsweise
die Polen die möglicherweise auch in
politische Themen an der Stelle mit
bedienen dass die jetzt gar nicht so
schnell dabei sind das war vielleicht
nicht so zu erwarten aber ist nun mal
jetzt so ich weise auch noch online und
sie hatten gesagt
wie kann sowas passieren nicht ohne
Abstimmung alles unverbrüchlich unter
Medic sagt irgendwie naja gut also
doch diese klare Abstimmung diese klare
Abstimmung hat ja stattgefunden zwischen
ähm
Olaf Scholz und den Franzosen in
Amerikaner und das ist ja darauf auf
diese entscheidende Zusammenarbeit kommt
es auch an wir haben bisher alle ähm ähm
Vereinbarungen auch beispielsweise mit
Polen oder anderen über den Ring Tausch
ja mit unterstützt und ähm die Rufe nach
der
Exportgenehmigung für die für die
Leopard Panzer aus Polen waren immer
sehr deutlich aber die die tatsächlichen
Anträge die formalen Anträge waren ja
nie da und insofern ist es ja man hat
auch im Jahr von der von der Konferenz
in Ramstein berichtet dass dort gar
nicht eine große Menge von
Verteidigungsministern bereits die
Anträge die exporteinträge mit dabei
hatten also ohne so eine klare Linie man
da würde jetzt der Kanzler getrieben hat
es nicht gegeben aber beiden hat auf die
explizite Frage eines Journalisten ob er
auch bereit wäre
Kampfjets zu liefern und Raketen mit
größerer Reichweite ein ganz größtes no
gesagt in dieser emphatischen Betonung
wer eine rote Linie die schwer
zurückzunehmendes sie signalisiert auch
dass sie Amerikaner zwar bisher viel
geliefert haben aber nicht
uferlos in diesem Konflikt sich selbst
verschleißen
gewonnen werden egal das ist doch der
Punkt die uferlosigkeit ist auch genau
das Thema egal welche Entscheidung wir
treffen die wir wie gesagt immer auch
gemeinsam mit den Verbündeten Treffen am
nächsten Tag wenn überhaupt ist so lange
dauert ist die nächste Forderung da und
das macht natürlich die Debatte auch
irrsinnig schwierig deswegen darauf
glaube dieses darauf hat Olaf Schulz
auch so und so einigermaßen harsch
reagieren
dass diese Forderung kommt wenn doch die
Erfahrung ist egal wo man die rote Linie
hinmalt man muss nur laut genug schreien
irgendwann wird sie wieder gerissen wenn
Joe beiden
kommt das von ihnen auch an unsere
unsere Entscheidungen haben sich nie
nach Geschrei gerichtet sondern sie
haben sich vor allem nach der
Entwicklung auch der militärischen
Notwendigkeit
entwickelt und und die Haltung des
Bundeskanzlers an der Stelle war ja
jetzt ganz klar
natürlich auch nicht dem amerikanischen
Präsidenten folgen aber wir agieren
gemeinsam
aufgehört ich bin nach diesen nein
gefragt worden und habe
anstatt des Nein zu wiederholen erklärt
welche Prinzipien uns leiden und da muss
ich auch ganz deutlich sagen die waren
vom ersten Tag an klar wir haben zwei
Tage nach dem Überfall Putins
entschieden dass wir gemeinsam mit
verbündeten damals Schulter gestützte
Panzerabwehrraketen liefern was denn
also eine kleine Waffe ist man kann auch
sagen nicht schwer ja aber es war zwei
Tage nach dem Überfall Putins auf die
Ukraine klar wir liefern Waffen in ein
Kriegsgebieten im Laufe der Zeit und wir
sind übrigens ein zweiter Stelle im bei
den bei den Lieferungen von von von
Rüstung an die Ukraine weltweit
gemeinsam mit den Juden ein zweiter
Stelle im
ein ganz anderes da ja aber warum
genau das passiert was hier gerade auch
passiert
in der Frage dessen was wir liefern
immer transparent die Briten übrigens
nicht ehrlich gesagt macht man das
eigentlich auch nicht transparent ganz
anders als Herr Merkel verlangt in der
Demokratie ist sowas transparent sein
nein da gelten glaube ich wir haben über
andere Regeln über Führung gesprochen
die Frage wie bringt man auch eine
Bevölkerung hinter sich wie überzeugt
man ein Land davon dass bestimmte Dinge
leider dieses Unbehagen angesichts
dieser Konzentration von Waffen es wird
auch hier in dieser Runde klar und es
geht auch Herrn Häuschen nicht anders
der für die Lieferung von Kampfjet wäre
wenn ich ihn richtig verstehe oder sagt
es kann der Moment kommen an dem es
notwendig ist glaube wenn ich das kurz
sagen darf wir haben in der Tat das
Stimmen zu immer das geht dann jetzt
Panzer und jetzt Flugzeugen und so das
ist die falsche Reihenfolge wir müssen
ja sehen was passiert vor Ort und wie
können wir ihn helfen und jetzt würde
ich sagen wenn sie mit Militär ist
sprechen sie sagen Panzer ist
normalerweise im Einsatz im Verbund da
brauchen sie Artillerie dann brauchen
die eventuell auch Flugzeuge zu aber das
muss man militärisch sehen also wer muss
es sehen von wie ist der der
militärische Bedarf und nicht immer was
ist so das nächste Instrument und da
kann es sein dass das auch
Kampfflugzeuge notwendig sind übrigens
gibt es auch in Amerika also diese
Bemerkung des Präsidenten Herr Merkel
die hat er auf dem Weg bei Journalisten
auf dem Zuruf gekommen also da gibt es
in Amerika in der Verwaltung in der
Verwaltung gibt es nämlich in
Administration gibt es dazu
unterschiedliche Unterschiede Stimmen
ein Punkt noch zu den Panzern das war
gar nicht kam gar nicht hier von der
Münchner sicherheitskampf von den von
einem stink Tank in in Berlin die sehr
früh gesagt haben als Panzer warum kann
Deutschland nicht
als die Diskussion aufkam als das Land
was Leopard hergestellt hat was
Exportgenehmigung
geben muss für jedes Land was ja warum
können Sie nicht in einem Art Konsortium
die Führung übernehmen und es war
übrigens nicht so er Merkel dass das nur
Osteuropäer waren die ersten die im Juni
im Juni letzten Jahr schon gefragt haben
wann die Spanier ja die ganz hinten
jetzt stehen bei der reality wie bei der
ich sag ja nur die Spanier haben als
erstes wenn man seinerzeit und dann
wurde ihn bedeutet bitte über den von
wegen ansteckend
dann früh gesagt hätte wir machen
Übernehmen von Europe
macht ein Konsortium und dann geht ihr
alle da rein alle die ein Leopard Panzer
und dann überleg Dir wie könnte er ein
Paket machen und da finde ich hätte man
Führung zeigen können indem man das
macht dann hätte man im Rammstein Format
die nehmen können hätten die Amerikaner
mit reinnehmen können hätten wir Führung
bewiesen so haben wir dann gewachtet so
im Ergebnis dass jetzt im Ergebnis jetzt
wir genau gar nicht genau wissen wer
stellt Anträge wer liefert dann kam auch
sehr überraschend dass das der Typ bei
Leopard A6 und ich ja fünf oder vier es
gibt ja unterschiedliche und das hätte
man schon vorher machen wichtig ist dass
es im Ergebnis passiert ist aber es hat
eben gedauert und da kommt dieses Bild
von Deutschland dass wir in diesen
Sachen überall zögern und und zaubern
finde ich kommt hinzu ja also und
deswegen finde ich das Nein zu Kampfjets
im Moment für den Moment auch richtig
ich glaube wir sollten uns jetzt mal auf
das konzentrieren was vor Ort wirklich
nötig ist und wenn ich das richtig sehe
fehlt bald die Munition das ist ja
eigentlich in alarmierendes Zeichen ja
dass wir da sozusagen die die Geparden
und die Marder hin liefern ja nach
quälenden Debatten nach ganz langen
Entscheidungen stehen die jetzt da
werden gebraucht und plötzlich ein paar
Wochen stehen die dann nutzlos rum mehr
wie in so Militärmuseum ich meine das
wäre doch ein Schildbürgerstreich wenn
das passieren würde dann muss es doch
jetzt meine klare munitionsstrategie
auch geben ja nicht nur der muss auch
der Bundesregierung des gesamten Westens
im Grunde genommen dass dieser Nachschub
organisiert wird ja dass die maintenance
und so weiter dass das alles organisiert
wird weil dieser Krieg der endet nicht
in zwei Monaten ja das wird ein langer
ein sehr sehr langer Krieg wenn man sich
den Putin anguckt und wir handelt ja
wenn man die Situation in bachmut und so
sein sich an was ist denn das
strategische Ziel dass beide Seiten
ermattet sind in einem
abnutzungskrieg die Toten nicht mehr
hinnehmen können Putin kann viel mehr
Tote hinnehmen als es die Ukraine kann
was soll denn das Ziel sein Ermattung
der Kriegs Kontrahenten und dann kommt
die Stunde der Diplomatie auf was warten
wir eigentlich selbst wenn die Chancen
gering sind
Verhandlungen haben ihre eigene Logik
ihre eigene Dynamik der
maximalpositionen verschwinden in aller
Regel in solchen Verhandlungen die sind
extrem schwer aber die auf habe von
solchen Verhandlungen weil man sagt
jetzt gehen die nicht dann muss ich
fragen fehlt uns das strategische Ziel
zu sagen wir schätzen dass wir Putin
besiegen können mit mehr Munition mit
Kampfjets und so weiter ist das das Ziel
ich habe und höre keine klaren Aussagen
über das strategische Ziel und die gibt
ja auch nicht immer in der
Regierungskoalition ist
das stimmt
nein
diesen Satz ganz bewusst und ganz
störrisch diesen Satz die Ukraine darf
diesen Krieg nicht verlieren er wird
immer wieder gefragt heißt das die
Ukraine mussten Krieg gewinnen er sagt
diesen Satz ganz bewusst nicht weil er
weiß in dem Moment wo Russland den Krieg
eventuell verlieren kann vermutlich der
brisanteste
riskanteste Moment des ganzen Krieges da
ist sozusagen die Ukraine darf nicht
verlieren ist doch ein Ziel ja
wir müssen gewinnen aber was ist
eigentlich das strategische Ziel lässt
sich sehr klar beantworten habe ich
vorher auch gemacht wir müssen dahin
kommen das Putin seine Niederlage
einsieht und da geht es nicht um eine
militärische Niederlage sondern es geht
darum sein Kriegsziel
die demokratische Welt zu spalten dass
er das nicht erreichen kann und dass wir
gemeinsam diese Aggression zurückweisen
und dann geht es tatsächlich um die
territorial
der Unternehmen wird der Westen und
kleine Kompaktheit verlieren der wissen
wie wir gehört haben schließt schon ein
Lateinamerika ausschließlich in Asien
heraus
das was Putin hofft dass genau eben das
wir sagen also wir halten es nicht durch
deswegen strecken wir jetzt die
Wasseruhr das ist realistisch oder das
ist gar nicht realistisch gucken Sie
doch wie viel Menschen jeden Tag gehört
haben ja aber es geht doch um die
Menschen in Ukraine die werden jeden Tag
sterben doch Menschen aufgrund
werden natürlich muss er beendet werden
aber sie können doch nicht jetzt sagen
also bitte bitte Vladimir hör auf zu
schießen er hört nicht auf wir haben
doch ich habe doch eben dargestellt wir
haben über Jahre alles versucht
diplomatisch hinzu und dass er seine
Autonomie für den ganzen Netz bekommen
dass wir wir haben alles versucht rund
um die Uhr um ihn und er will es einfach
nicht er glaubt dass er die Sowjetunion
wiederherstellen kann und der wird alles
tun wenn wir ihn nicht stoppen wir
bekommen ihn nicht dahin an den
Verhandlungstisch ich meine der
Bundeskanzler ruft ihn ja regelmäßig an
er geht kein Jota ab es gibt natürlich
übrigens Verhandlungen es gibt ein
Verhandlungen darum ob man Gefangenen
Austausch macht ist und die sind
natürlich immer bereit das ist wichtig
und da ähm so ein äh Griff ist von der
versucht ja auch dann vielleicht kann
man etwas mehr bekommen putin will es
nicht weil er glaubt dass er stärker ist
dass er uns besiegt dass wir uns
innerlich zersetzen und sagen also wir
geben dir keine auf genau
Rationalität ich glaube nicht dass Putin
ihrer Zimmer ist genau
dass wir nicht durchhalten ja meine
kleine Frage wenn die Aussage richtig
ist der Ukraine gehen weniger die Waffen
als die Menschen aus wir wissen genau
dass Nato-Soldaten nicht in diesen Krieg
unser ground sich bewegen können weil
das sozusagen ein ein
Weltkriegsszenario tatsächlich denkbar
macht was haben wir denn dann zu tun wo
setzen sie denn die Möglichkeit von
Verhandlungen an sie sagen wir müssen
den Krieg weiterführen Putin muss
einziehen was ist wenn er das nicht tut
weil nicht nur seine politische sondern
seine physische Existenz daran hängen
kann wenn er diesen Krieg sichtbar
verliert also sie sagen haben
Putin hat mehr Menschen haben sie
festgestellt wie die Bevölkerung
reagiert hat als diese teilmobil machen
bekannt gemacht wurde und plötzlich
Familienväter ähm einberufen wurden
wieder reagiert gemacht und trotzdem
kann es wieder machen weil es keine
Effekt
Opposition die hat der sozusagen aus dem
Land gedrängt oder in Gulags geschickt
die verlassen das sind immer noch nicht
er kann es aber
Merkel aber zu den Ukrainern wir haben
bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz geben wir den
sogenannten Munich Security Report raus
und da haben wir Umfragen gemacht in
auch in der Ukraine wie stehen sie zum
Krieg und eine über 90% sagen wir
kämpfen durch wir wissen was uns
passiert wenn wir aufgeben dann passiert
uns das was eben in Botschaft anderswo
passiert ist dann haben wir eine Frage
gestellt und das muss man sich auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen was macht ihr in
der Ukraine wenn Putin taktische
Nuklearwaffen einsetzt
89 % der Ukrainer sagen wir kämpfen
weiter also die Ukrainer wissen was
Besetzung durch Russland heißt sie
stehen da die die kämpfen um ihr Leben
die sehen ja was passiert ist an
Tötungen an Vergewaltigung da werden
Kinder entführt und alles lieber Herr
Merkel sie können die Ukraine nicht
davon abhalten dass sie ihre Freiheit
und wir müssen sie unterstützen und wir
haben eben gesagt moralisch
vor 80 Jahren hat sie deutsche Wehrmacht
in babinja an einem Wochenende
30.3 jüdische Ukrainer umgebracht
und da haben wir aus meiner Sicht einem
moralische Verpflichtung die zu
unterstützen und nicht eine moralische
Verpflichtung und rauszuhalten